foreign
[Music]
Linda Ronstadt music hall June 17th I am
going to be there doing my show that is
the Don't Push Me Tour that is the time
I will be uh that is my next tour date
June 17th Pueblo Colorado June 23rd June
24th Colorado Springs Charlotte North
Carolina almost sold out Knoxville
Tennessee Little Rock Arkansas why am I
going there and uh so it's on and
popping my babies
um a bunch of other ones too I'm doing
Canada uh Montreal is almost sold out
um so that's what's up Redding I'm gonna
be reading Reading Pennsylvania
Philadelphia Pennsylvania Baltimore [__]
that's how I like to go I like to go be
more I like to go be more though anyway
um I like to go be more memorable you
know what I mean
um
yeah so uh you know what I mean
so anyway dude welcome to the next the
next the new episode of congratulations
you're crazy congratulations
[Music]
hey yo what's up players and playettes
dude that's how I do it I gotta be like
that I gotta say play as a play that's
like I'm a dad I'm a dad dude I got two
kids now I gotta say players and play
ads and stuff what up guys hey how's it
going well how's it going what's up 50
Cent 50 Cent when people when dads do
that 50 oh yeah it's 50 Cent wow it's so
dead to even be talking about 50 Cent at
all because of how 50 Cent is how old is
50 Cent I literally have no idea I'm
looking up 50 Cent
age
here we go 47 years old nice
good good for him good for him
uh
uh 50 Cent really be really really be
balling huh got making money
took Court of War
two quarter water put it in the market
and then put it in it's in the stores
what the heck or whatever the song kids
had f word yet because we just started
the podcast anyway do it I need to get
more yachts
um
and was a dude oh oh so dude first of
all I can subscribe oh and you know what
get that grow or die merch that that's
just popping that's just flying off this
[__]
says flying off the shelves grow or die
Merchant got the hoodie you got the the
uh the two different versions it's
really really really
um really cool and I see him out it
shows man people would be wearing my
merch out at the shows that's the
uniform whoops
that's the uniform when people say
people are wearing your merchandise I go
that's a uniform
so um
yeah I was in where was I this past
weekend where was I I was in Salt Lake
City and the other one was Boise I have
never been more famous than when I'm in
Boise I swear to God and so that's good
so thank you so so good job me thank you
very much dude uh walk down the street
and everybody wanted pictures it's all
good I don't know what's going on with
Boise I thought Boise wasn't as I say
Boise because I'm like I'm like that I'm
like the locals dude that's what they
that's what they say when people say
Boise
cringe because that's not what it is is
it a z no it actually looks like Boise
it does but it's Boise that's what it is
and um
I was in uh Boise and it was awesome I
played my I played an arena I played the
first uh Arena I ever played
um what they do is they split it down
the middle there and then you play to
one half uh so you know maybe next time
I go back I play the whole thing right
like I'm a like I'm a team
but it was the hockey arena it was
really cool and um it was actually while
playing an arena they got that delay
like you say something and then it and
then you hear it and then also
everyone's way more drunk in an arena
for some reason an arena is just like a
theater is nice like I played Salt Lake
City I'll get to that
in a little bit but
um I played Salt Lake City uh but and
the theater was beautiful we'll get to
that but it was uh a big theater and
just nice Boise absolutely pandemonium
and it was you know
I mean just the drunk people some uh a
woman got kicked out in the front row
because when I got on stage she turned
around to everybody and started dancing
she started dancing and I was like okay
listen you got to sit down and then she
was like very loud and very drunk and
very obnoxious and so then I said
they're gonna throw you out you know I
I'm really I'm you know I'm pulling for
you and uh she was like uh kept talking
and then they threw her out and then
every time someone gets thrown out this
is their face when I look out in the
audience they go like this
well be person
the thing is piece of [__] right be a
person instead of piece of [__]
and her and the woman she was with had
to leave and the dudes that they're with
stayed so Props to them dude that is the
most best thing you can do in the world
so that's so cool if you're if uh if
your chickered dude gets thrown out and
you stay or if you're a homie and your
homie gets thrown out and you stay or if
you're you know having a girls night and
one of the ladies gets thrown out and
then the other lady stays that's Ballin
and people who come to my shoulder
balling so uh did Boise it was really um
fun dude I said this before on this
podcast but I'm saying it again okay
Boise is absolutely it's it's an ill
place it is so so good it's rad it's
dope it's all that stuff that was
popular in the night and then saying
that stuff in the 90s no but it really
is very cool dude you like breweries
they got breweries at the Wazoo you like
coffee shops they got coffee shops out
to wazoo
you like walking around having a good
time they got walking around having a
good time at the zoo dude nice
restaurants check lime scooters check
out the Wazoo so we took live scooters
we hopped off yeah I was wearing
Balenciaga shoes and yeah I was wearing
walking around all day and on the live
scores yeah I hurt my [__] bones dude
it wasn't even you know how you this is
how bad the Balenciaga shoes are now
they do they look absolutely do they
look do they look good absolutely right
does that look good yeah okay he puts
them on does it hurt yeah but it's
fashion pain yeah
so does he wear them anyway yeah
so I put on the balenciagas I walked
around and oh my God it hurts so bad and
it wasn't even the skin you know how
some shoes are bad on your feet and they
give you blisters Balenciaga goes like
this we're gonna take one further dude
we're gonna hurt your bones
we're gonna make it think like you broke
your feet
yeah we don't [__] with the skin we [__]
with the bones so there you go
Spurs for you
um my feet hurt still like I'm an old
lady like I have plantar fasciitis and
it's unbelievable now do the bun Saga
shoes look amazing yes they do are they
you know what I mean
yeah so I wore them in there and they're
great but they fashion is pain and so I
kept on and then I had to take them off
whatever dude this podcast I talk about
the hard-hitting issues and right now
we're talking about my foot pain so
[Music]
um
was on the lime scooters bolted around
Boise
heard this a lot
and and then
took a flight
2. Salt Lake City
boy Boise
is awesome okay
Boise is awesome
Salt Lake City
awesome okay now both awesome
different reasons Boise first of all and
this isn't why it's good but I just want
you to know what you're getting into
no blacks there unless you bring them
okay
I have two people who helped me do my
show they go on before me they're both
they both happen to be black don't care
about if they are or not I mean I care
for them that's nice you know live the
culture and do all that right opener
equal opportunity doesn't matter right
brought them they were the only blacks
there in Idaho I don't understand what's
up with Idaho but I do kind of you're
going to be like well what's the whitest
place you might be like well Idaho is up
there right
we saw Zero other black people zero zero
zero you understand
um
and they killed it dude shout out to
Lulu Gonzalez and Danny love
um but yes we were in Boise and it was
great
um
man I would I would honestly uh here we
go he's gonna say it isn't he what no no
he's not well yeah he is no no no no
make sure he doesn't say it man but
we're live we're live yeah no I know
anyway nobody's gonna say it he can't do
it he's got a mind of his own I would
live in Boise there I said it
dude he said it off [__] ah [__] what
are we gonna do I should be okay it's
actually okay you know what just let it
fly
it's so nice
I remember Aaron Paul was telling me
that because he's from there and I was
like all right dude you know but is it
really that great dude first time I
performed there he came up to watch with
his family and friends bro name drop
course but also
he's a friend so go you know go [__]
yourself bro it was so good I'm like
this place really is this really is
bawling and he was like yeah man I told
you
uh so then got on the plane to Salt Lake
City God you gotta fly which sucks
gotta fly I don't like to fly
I don't like to fly from I like to fly
in drive to another one fly back I don't
like to fly in fly to another one and
then fly back right
because why because too much jet lag to
got to Salt Lake City
and this theater the Eccles theater
is so good
then he said it best he's like man this
[__] of Rolls Royce it is it's got the
the stars on the top
and uh
2 500 people came out Whoopsie Daisy
right they kept the same seats warm but
not too warm right because they stand up
sometimes well they stand up at the
front and at the end and then also
sometimes in the middle don't they yeah
yeah yeah they do
yeah they do
um that's like the holy spirit in them
they stand up and they go yeah yeah
um
Salt Lake City
is another great place because of
here here's my theory
I have a theory do you want to hear my
theory on stand-up and cities it's a
great Theory and it's probably my best
theory that's probably the most true of
all my theories
okay
is
if you're in
if you're the best places are to perform
in
if you're a comedian that pushes the
envelope and we know
I push the envelope because I want to
you know
I'm going to say what's funny not what's
not offensive right
uh
uh and yeah yeah and so I'm gonna push
the envelope and also I'm embattled
right so it's like
either way I know you either love
crystalia or you hate crystalia but
those who ride with me dude
you know what I'm talking about
just vests just leather vests on
with spikes on the shoulder so Birds
can't land on us
um
but my theory about comedy and cities is
if you're somebody who pushes the
envelope as a comedian
you they
these cities who that are either
known as woke or religious like Goody
Two-Shoes right like Salt Lake City is
that's the idea of Salt Lake City people
like oh that's the Mormon place where
everybody is just trying to have family
and you know they get they probably get
offended they probably just don't you
did you swear in front of them
or Portland where you go and you're like
oh shoot are they gonna uh you know like
they were trying to pretend like there
was gonna be a protest for one of my
shows and there wasn't there were two
people out there it was hilarious the
media was trying to be like Dad there
was a pro there was a there's gonna be a
huge protest everyone's aligned and
there were two people out there with one
sign
and 2 700 people walk by them and so
so uh
so those are the best cities to perform
in because they're known for that and
the people who like you as a comedian
are gonna make sure that you understand
that they're not that
so they come out and they laugh
so and I you know when I thought of this
theory in Salt Lake City the first time
I ever went there I was like this
probably gonna be hard because there's
like a lot of people who are probably
don't want me to like say the things I'm
gonna say bro and I did it and I was
like why is this crowd so good and they
were like yeah this car comes out and I
was like and then I thought about it
some more and then I noticed especially
when I was in Seattle and and
um Portland those were two of the best
shows that I've had so
yeah Salt Lake was awesome
um hey dude I'm gonna be real with you
guys sup with the
uh you know the dudes too but the but
but the the women in in Salt Lake City
okay dude we landed in Salt Lake City a
a a [__]
like lingerie model got off the what got
off a plane uh
a pilot with a Pilot hat on with her
thing and I'm like bro
where everyone goes what the [__] even
the I was we were with everybody Lulu
was a what
in Salt Lake City everybody
dude the attractive scale goes to 11.
the pilots are nines huh the chick
Pilots hey what in in Salt Lake City
I saw a chick I saw a female pilot first
of all how many honestly female Pilots
do you see what's the percentage
and then how many of them look like men
high percentage
and on top of that how many of them look
like unattractive men high percentage
dude this diamond in the rough came out
and you just go oh
huh
and she's flying planes all over the
place dude God imagine being
on her flight
everyone's just
we're gonna make me
gonna make it
oh oh that yeah sorry I thought maybe
the
I didn't realize it was gonna be you
that came out sorry
dude
just hi I'm your pilot
you know what I mean it's gonna be a
little bit of turbulence so just like
buckle up or whatever
hmm
uh
um we're gonna be serving drinks wow you
know it's just sexist
but it was crazy dude and and and then
at the show the women that come out most
fittest women just like
no fatsos in Salt Lake City and I know
that that's not true but where are they
right they're probably on the outskirts
the dudes are just like hey and and the
women are like
just
I mean they look like
God damn dude so I'm just like okay but
also let's get on to my family
um
Salt Lake City is awesome man had such a
good time uh
when I was on the way to Salt Lake City
this drove me [__] absolutely Bonkers
I was on the plane
I'm about about to you know reward and I
gotta go to the bathroom right but I'm
like I could wait
okay
um
was this a salt liquor this is this was
the Boise actually from LAX to Boise
I get on a plane
I gotta go to the bathroom we're taking
off as we take off I'm in the first seat
right and the the the the
what do you call them the stewardess is
in the jump seat right which is
facing me you know what I'm saying
and I say uh
hey uh I am I
um as we're taking off I say hey will
you do me a favor to the lady he says
yeah I said is it possible for you to
tell me
when I can what the earliest time is for
me to go to the bathroom after we get in
the air because we're we're attacked we
were getting in the air and she says now
I say this why do I say this because
immediately all of a sudden I'm gonna
[__] my pants okay right and it's the
most inopportune time because I'm
strapped in I can't do it right
I can't go to the bathroom because I
mean dude you're not gonna stop me I'll
tell you that I'm not gonna [__] my
pants there's no way that's happening
we could be taken off and as we're taken
off
I'm gonna shoot my pants or [__] in the
bathroom I'm gonna go to the bathroom so
I'm gonna take the thing off I'm gonna
be it'll be like Inception where I'm
trying to like you know climb the walls
and then I'm gonna get into that
bathroom and just you know what I mean
try my best to only get it in the toilet
but I say to where I say when let me
know please the earliest time
and she says I will okay sounds good we
just have to get a little bit higher so
we can level out and I say fantastic I'm
gonna hold it until then
now I didn't like that I had to do that
but I needed to know when the earliest
time was because now I know what's going
to happen is
whenever she knows it's possible to do
it she goes she's going to go like this
go ahead look at me and say go ahead so
I got this [__] right nobody's gonna get
the bathroom before me all right now
there's two dudes next to me one who's
right next to me he's a big fan he's
from Orange County okay and he's talking
to me mostly you know he's talking to me
because he's a fan but he's also mostly
talking to me because he's live about
six drinks in [__] um 30 minutes of
the flight or 30 minutes after we sat
down which is we're taking off
and then there's another guy across the
way right it's two seats me and a guy
and then one across the way this dude
after I say hey can I you tell me no
when I could go to the bathroom early
and stuff this dude leans in to the to
the steward on the jump seat and says
hey
she says yeah and he says can I go after
him
[Music]
hey
dude
what are you doing
what are you doing let's let's explore
all these options okay
first of all why did I say
I do this kind of [__] I don't even
understand people
obviously I gotta go bad okay
so I asked when is it okay to do it
there that's it I didn't want to have
I'm one of those guys I don't want to
[__] put people out I don't want to
have 30 answers I don't want her to
think I gotta go potty so bad she
doesn't know if I go to number one or
number two I gotta go number two and
she'll know afterwards
and then the guy leans up to her and
says can I go after him and she says
you want to go after him
and he says yeah would that be okay
and I looked at him and I said why
wouldn't
said well of course it would be okay for
you to go after me because that's during
the flight and he says yeah
so now I'm in a situation to where I'm
with the weird guy
everything was normal and then that guy
made us a group right that guy made us
together that's what he made now we're
the two guys who are B Because me I'm
not being annoying I'm simply asking the
question when he chimed in now we're the
annoying guys that are asking about the
bathroom so now I'm like you know what I
want to [__] my pants I want this guy to
deal with it but then I realize he's
gonna go after me awesome because I
gotta go number two and now he's got to
deal with it so in a way it was like
Instant Karma I go in there plop plop
leave I see this dude come in and I go
have a fun day I can't even pretend it's
not me right and a matter of fact I was
the first one dude have you ever been
the first one to use the toilet in an
airplane
yo you know how clean it is I bet you
don't know that because after one person
uses it it looks like a dog died in it
right it literally looks like just
it's a mess
and I was like whoa this is clean dude I
had to go number two guess what I didn't
even use the paper to put it down on the
[__] toilet paper I on the uh on the
uh on the toilet seat I don't do that
dude
how about that how gangster is that
I know I said I didn't use that on H on
H3 when I did H3 and it's the truth I
don't even use it I don't even use it in
an airplane bathroom now unless it's
also unless it's a mess which of course
it was a mess after I mean if you guys
used it but then the other dude next to
me went to go use that some after the
second guy and he came back and I was
like yo sorry bro I blew that [__] up he
was like yeah it's okay man I was gonna
ask if I should wait but who cares and I
was like yeah yeah that's that's what
somebody for most people do and say
um
yeah man don't
that's annoying when somebody [__]
makes you be somebody about that you you
know you learn oh hey happy birthday to
Brody Stevens is today the 22nd Monday
the 22nd happy birthday to Brodie
Stevens he would have been 53 today
um one of my favorite comedians that
ever lived a great friend loved that
dude and um
yep he passed away
um
five years ago maybe yeah
it was sad
um and we love him I loved him he was so
funny the guy made me laugh more than
any more than anybody on stage No Doubt
uh I want to watch this guy this guy I
started following on Instagram
here we go all right we're back sorry
had to get all squared away here this
guy I follow on Instagram
and
I like this guy
because I love watching them
let's just look at some of these his
name's timoth Timon
uh Dot craik k-r-i-e-k
um let me go to a good one here I don't
really know what good what the good ones
are if I'm honest
let's go to this one
yeah yeah here we go here we go here we
go this was good hold on
hold on here we go call me what you want
I'd rather marry a smart caring and down
to earth five who I know is going to be
a good parent to my kids then Mario
tenure thinks they're the absolute [__]
and goes out every weekend
because at the end of the day
looks fade but personality stays
call me what you want it's worth again
I'd rather marry a smart caring and down
to earth five who I know to be a good
parent still using the numbers they're
the absolute [__] and goes out every
weekend
dude first of all supporting women but
also still using the number scale you
know and then uh then then marrying a 10
or still thinks that the absolute [__]
like thinks they're the absolute [__]
dude oh man simple
I'd rather marry a five that is good to
my kids than someone who's attended that
things that they absolute [__] this
[__] [__]
let me get this straight if you start
talking to me every day and every night
I'm obviously going to get attached to
you yeah boy even if I never plan to I
will yeah so before you start getting
close make sure you won't suddenly
that seems to happen a lot in this
generation oh it's been so burned dude
been so burned man let me get this
straight
wow that guy I mean oh this is bad for
dudes this is bad for dudes you know
so many creepsters out there like
finally do the guy that gets it
don't be mad at me for not leaving you
alone I'm trying to protect you you know
I'll be honest oh boy here we go I've
been hurts and wears I can't explain in
words oh you could so until someone
shows me that this generation isn't just
hookups
ah dude and I need you at the moment
culture I need you at the moment culture
you know
trying to make merch
I'm gonna do myself a favor and stay
single yeah
dude I'll be honest this part I've been
hurt some ways I can't explain in words
good
Jesus fed five thousand but only 500
followed him after lunch
he had 12 disciples but only three went
further in the garden
and only one stood with him at the cross
the closer you get to the cross the
smaller the crowd becomes
but that's okay because I choose quality
over quantity every time dude means
nothing just say quality over quantity
you know
maybe like
yeah oh god dude I want to be this guy's
friend so bad I love this guy and I'm
not I don't know some of the [__] I'm
laughing good I will I would hang out
with this guy till the ends of the Earth
and my that's what my brother my brother
knows that dude ask him
which is the one that was really got me
here are my top tips for this generation
dude talking speaking to his generation
is the most awesome [__]
[Music]
day to marry
friendship tip forgive
self-cater masturbating read the Bible
mental tip how long is a guy who does
self-care and [__] reads the Bible
hold on prayer helps yeah
eternity
Jesus saves
ah yeah the last three were the same
eternity tip Jesus saves
[__] uh
what was the he always walks away my top
tips for this generation dude
relationship tips day to marry
date to marry friendship tip forget it
there we go Jesus self-care
read the Bible there we go mental tip
think about it yourself there we go
eternity tip I mean Jesus eternity tip
dude
[Laughter]
that's what I call my penis
eternity tip wear a condom
Arnold Schwarzenegger
I hate to break it to you oh Yoda but
all they treat you is how they feel
about you don't try to decode it or make
excuses it's simple if they act like
they don't care they don't care because
if they truly like you they'd never put
you in a position where you have to
wonder why they're acting the way they
are wow what if you looked and you
zoomed in on my podcast and I was crying
with that one
oh my God
I love it
let me get this straight this is the one
right this is the one
this is the one we were laughing at this
is the one oh this is the one dude let
me get this
oh confused
like get the crew and the mic we need to
go out and make one of these videos
if you start talking to me every day and
every night I'm obviously going to get
attached no we already showed that one
God damn it which is the one dude
you know what I'm gonna find it because
we were we were texting about it hold on
we gotta find it this is the one
where is it here we go
um
hold on the five one yeah what does that
mean
no no no it's this one it's this one
did
holy [__]
it's all fun at games until I'm
unreachable hold on I want to find it in
the thing though
damn it
no I know but oh yeah I could do that
right wow that's an idiot
oh man
or I can look can I look at
oh God it's all fun and games until I'm
unreachable
hold on
ah this is the best
here we go here we go
here we go
here we go here we go yes dude
here we go this is the best one dude
come on
oh guys just bear with me I know I know
it's all fun and games until I'm
unreachable because listen I'm sorry for
your loss
but I'm not available no more
because I gotta protect my energy
as a matter of fact
I'll go ghost before I let myself be
taken advantage of
defeated the
purpose dude I'll go ghost before I let
myself get taken advantage of dude the
[__] it's all fun and games until I'm
unreachable dude that line it sold fun
and games until I'm unreachable like
that is killing your next of kin
like that's like well dude you know you
don't want to [__] with him why
oh man you haven't heard about him well
what does he do like beat the [__] out
of you what no dude even worse oh well
what is it
I can't be able to get a hold of him
try all I'm saying is
it's all fun and games until you try to
send a text out did you [__] with him
yeah try to send a text out now what
happened it's green in it so now what he
blocked you
know where you do know where he lives
okay well then I guess it's not oh never
mind oh he moved
it's all fun and games until you're on
reach until I'm unreachable
I want to tell you Kings today that
there's no benefit in chasing women
God says chasing women in Proverbs 31
verse 3 do not waste your strength on a
woman on those who ruined Kings no if
God blesses you with a Godly woman along
your journey that's great but don't go
out of your way seeking the validation
of these modern day women God I mean
always remember a man loses the moment
he puts a woman over his purpose I mean
dude gets so [__] Undercover exist
dude
So Undercover just [__] been so
burned by a modern woman that it's
unbelievable
went out with a modern woman three times
and then she started like saw someone
else and then he just simply can't get
over it
[__] his brother you know
he unfollowed his brother and started
making these videos
thank you
the guy's the best
Timon
I love them everyone should follow him
you know what it's how it goes
it's how it goes and so it goes and so
it goes oh [__] what happened everything
went away on my computer great yes
um
why'd everything go away
oh there it is
dude I have to think about the last
[__] three years that I've been like
actually I was thinking about this the
last three years just how [__] hard
it's been for like me and my family and
all that just like with the recovery and
all that and I'm just so grateful that
everyone of like my shows are sold out
uh and that people come to see me and
um you know it's been a long road of
recovery and it's hard and it's you know
um
it's a lot it's just uh constant work
I'm working on myself that I have to do
and that um to make sure I keep you know
my shot of the street clean and I'm just
grateful for everybody that's been um
like along my journey and really been
following it you know I mean I know I
know that the [__]
look the media is the media and it's
going to do what it does
um and it's [__] up because uh
uh you know my wife and I are trying to
[__] navigate through the past three
years and it's hard but I you know
people say to me like oh thank you for
coming I wanna see people say I thank
you for coming back a lot in the meet
and greets they say thank you so much
for for coming back and and finding a
way to get back on stage and talk about
all this stuff and Recovery especially
because I deal with a lot of like a lot
of addicts are coming to my shows and
all that
um and they you know they talk to me
about it afterwards and I I want to be
very clear that
um if it wasn't for because someone was
asking me literally today they were like
how do you deal with she was asking me
about this I ran into her and she was
asking me about this because she was
going through [__] and she's like how do
you cope with the things that people say
about you uh that aren't true the things
that people say about you that make you
feel like [__] and
um I I this is what made me think of
this because like I've done so much work
on myself over the past three years and
a lot of therapy and it's really it's
really hard to deal with because she was
going through her own thing she was
talking about this and um I was telling
her it's not easy but you have to know
who you are in the face of people who
are telling you that you're something
that you're not and
um
so for that I'm grateful for everybody
that rocks with me but I I want to say
that
you can't get past [__] without being
grateful and for me the number you don't
don't thank me thank
the reason why I'm back doing what I'm
doing is because of my wife the reason
why is because of my family
I talk about this in my ACT but
my wife held me the [__] down and
there was no way I could have gotten
through that without her and
yes of course without Calvin and now
William however they can't really have
complex conversations and the
conversations that I've had with my wife
throughout these past years of struggle
uh mentally and through sobriety and all
that stuff
just she
you know I was thinking about this now
too because the guy was talking about
get don't date a modern woman like
whatever a modern woman is like you know
that's funny that he's talking about
that and I'm making fun of it but
that
she is a woman who is now
so you could argue she's a modern woman
this woman
is
I mean an angel sent to Earth it's
unbelievable how she has helped me and
you know I used to hate when people say
like she this person's my rock but man
it's it's tough when you're broken and
and someone else has to take the weight
and they make you better and uh so I
guess in a way I'm saying don't thank me
thank her uh
I would not be here if it wasn't for her
and I would not I would certainly not be
doing
um these uh these podcasts
um so that's that I you know I don't
like getting serious on this podcast but
sometimes I I like it you know
um but anyway I I just appreciate you
you [__] man like you're so
awesome
and I'm so grateful for you
um
and uh you know that's it I don't know
people [__] identify with that at all
or not but
that's what's up
and then the bottom line is you know
it's all fun and games until I'm
unreachable so uh
uh there was a thing
by the way also also
you know what we went to uh the day I
got back from Salt Lake City I went to
uh
I got home I was so tired I don't even
know why it wasn't a long flight or
anything and I got enough sleep over the
weekend but
we went I said let's go because I you
know I said let's take Calvin
William was already asleep
um with the nanny but I was like let's
take Calvin Alice do something what do
you want to do when Chris was like I
don't know I was like let's go somewhere
and
she said uh okay
and so we said what do you want to do
Calvin
and he said I'll get hot chocolate so we
went anybody calls he says because he
knows I like coffee so I was like let's
go get coffee so it's really cute so I
want to go get coffee and then we walked
by an ice cream place and Calvin fell
asleep on my arms
and then we went to the ice cream place
and we're like buddy wake up and he was
not waking up we got the ice cream and
we showed him the ice cream and my buddy
wake up and he opened his eyes and
looked at ice cream and then closed his
eyes back again and then Kristen was
like do you want ice cream and he goes
like this
and so we took the thing and we get gave
it to him and he had his eyes closed and
he goes like this
I mean she put it in his mouth and he
ate it and he goes
and he's sleeping eating ice cream
sleeping the kids got the life
what is this [__] that [__]
Kevin Sorbo tweeted Bill Gates is done
you know for what
wow imagine you dude hey like
Kevin sorbo's nuts dude
Kevin Sorbo saying Bill Gates is done
Kevin Sorbo played [__] Krull
oh crawl the Conqueror by the way I love
Republicans so this isn't me bashing
Republicans Kevin Sorbo super Republican
what's the opposite of woke
um
uh
Bill Gates is done dude
what a great tweet
red pilled yeah
it's crazy this the Twitter uh
look at this fake Pentagon attack hoax
shows Perils of Twitter's paid
verification I didn't realize I don't
have Twitter you know I mean I I have
had Twitter for years but I haven't used
it and I looked uh I never look at my my
Twitter
but uh I noticed that my check mark went
away because I don't pay right is that
what it is wow so I you don't even get
one if you're a celebrity I didn't know
that because you know let's let's
[__] face it dude
I'm a man about town people know me
um fake Pentagon attack hook shares
personal Twitter surprisingly literally
no one a combination of paid blue checks
in general oh this is a [__] already
seems like a woke article
um
on Monday morning is seemingly AI
generated image of an explosion of the
Pentagon circulator around the internet
even though the event didn't actually
happen
okay
um
no I don't want to [__]
upload Adobe you know uh
the dangers of the pay to verify system
the account was tweeted so Bloomberg
feed
that is a blue check mark tweeted that
wow looks like a legit Bloomberg feed
and then people will believe it right
people have started believing it now
they think see this is [__] up dude
now they think that that [__] happened
it's so crazy how much misinformation is
out there and how much it actually
affects real life case in point um
because I go I think people hate me and
then I show up to my shows and I'm like
oh never mind real life is [__]
Bonkers awesome people see through the
[__]
um look at this it got
it's AI generated dude this picture
I mean it looks AI generated you know
there's a gold check
oh really for businesses that means it's
first folks saying just get the gold
check look at the New York Times Pages
all of these are tied uh to the company
but the badge system does absolutely
nothing to help the average user know
which event you're legit I mean I guess
I don't know [__] it whatever
damn I didn't even know there was a cold
check mark till now
everybody's [__] sincerely crystalia
oh bro this is so funny
[Music]
you're saying I believe you know Pastor
we're just giving an opportunity to
confess and before men he sees you a
little guy in the back
little guy I'm not a [__] he's a oh
boy he's a child I mean the guitar yeah
I wanted to think I was offending a
[__] the guitar oh David Brent
your hand it's because you already
believe the exhale you're sick I believe
you know and we've just given an
opportunity to confess and before men he
sees you a little guy in the back
getting so bad getting worse I'm not a
[__] he's a I mean he's a child I mean
I don't have anyone to think I was
offending a [__] have you ever seen
someone dig a hole so hard
the exhale dude
the best dude I mean like
over there little guy don't wanna I mean
not a a [__] a child not that admit I
don't mean I'm not trying to offend a
[__] but midgets are they're a little
person is what you would call them
anyway you wouldn't say [__] uh and it
doesn't matter if they are black or
white uh and or or Asian or Indian they
could do any job they want tech support
or any other job not because they're in
an Indian Indians can do any jobs they
could be doctors or Tech supports or
whatever I mean I know that's a
stereotype is that Indian uh not
certainly not Indian midgets they don't
usually become doctors not that they can
and they don't do also uh tech support
because uh they uh would need one of
those chairs that would raise up higher
than normal but and that's fine if they
did but oh my God I ah just Satan
bringing him down
yeah seriously [__] David Brent or
Michael Scott whatever one you use you
could say David Brent if you watched a
good version of the awesome office or
Michael Scott if you watch the one
that's not as good no offense I have
some you know some I like I like the
people on that office but
um
unbelievable says [__]
is that bad you can't say [__] right
dude
Jay Morant stop
having a gun
hours after NBA Commissioner Adams are
seeing other social media videos they
have it again with the gun just keeps on
carrying a gun dude get different
friends man
God guys gonna affect his [__] bag
isn't it
that's so funny silver the guy who he's
the guy who is a commissioner of the NBA
and he said honestly I was shocked when
I saw this weekend
when I saw this weekend that video why
did he say that that's weird that he
said that honestly I was shocked when I
saw the video this weekend dude oh no
[__] you'd be like get the are you
[__] serious honestly this guy oh God
it's so funny because he's from such a
nice upbringing
there's a whole meme where it's like
okay Mom bye dad Bye Mom I love you and
then he walks outside he's like yo
what's up cuz what's up [__]
the white kid
John Morant needs Jay Moran what is it
Jay I I don't do it it put in it put a y
on end of it
it's jaw like oh I'm the only other jaw
I know is Ja Rule
Ja Rule and John Moran
it's murder literally dude in his
[__] if he keeps carrying that gun
it's gonna be that's what I'm saying
dude
my legs are so sore from working out but
that's cool
only ugly's at my gym so that's good we
need to Uglies at my gym we need the
Uglies at my gym that's what we need
um
all right we haven't done this in a
while let's do miss connections um
West Side over on the west side this
one's called donut eater um
under that it says looking for those
that like to eat the donut signed M okay
well just to break it down we like to
break it down here uh and uh you know I
know it's kind of cagey how it's written
but he means uh anus right here so
that's what he means right
uh uh cause you could argue that it's
definitely what a female has but there
is no way a female uh posted this so
also females have anuses so and that's
just science so uh here's another one
you used to come to our pirate parties
Wilmington
you used to say yo ho Yoho the pirate's
life for me okay
swinging from the yardarm what's that
Good Times late night skullduggery
that guy's just a crazy person
um
what is this this one's so drunk this is
a straight guy did this one and it's so
and he's so drunk bro and bro it's
called and then another it says bro and
bro just for goes to USC you know
here we go coffee talk with mature lady
now that's something that my wife and I
would be into uh we meet few time for
coffee it's Russian we meet a few times
for coffee and had fun talking about
family and our granddaughter oh and your
granddaughter Jesus I was gonna be weird
uh we flirt a little bit and you were
interested to go further but kovid show
up
you were petite good shape because of
cycling in low 70s I believe
uh
so Russian
she was trying to get away from you bro
uh what is this did you peep my cheapers
so British did you peep my cheapers
what is going on
I beat my jeepers
it ain't tricky were you peeping my
peepee cheapers oh well absolutely
[__]
I mean what it ain't tricky where you
peeping my peepee cheapers are you
reading this now what kind of moribund
and self-attentive
Savor to stick with burbs I mean
who did this AI weird dude looking for
compliment also would accept a
compliment or two I mean
that's some [__] Rick Glassman would say
right there
weird dude looking for compliment also
would accept a compliment or two
making capital in a capital by teaming
with a teaming group I mean this is so
awful this is the worst one I've ever
read in my life
of principles without principles
what is this [__]
Fred Gwynn had some great books that had
homophonic fun thanks Mr Focus I'm the
only guy who ever read that by the way
you know
people got to the pp Jeepers and they
were like this is stupid I read the
whole [__] thing out loud guaranteed
nobody's read that out loud in the
[__] world
unreal dude
let's look at the deserve it scales
huh
okay
oh jumped into the car and he
and he's and he oh dude
what is the guy saying
you know
so British the guy
oh oh you smashed the windscreen he said
dude he jumped into the car as you jump
into the car the guy hit the brake so
hard and the guy smashed his windscreen
some British to say windscreen
smash me windscreen he smashed me
[__] windscreen
oh the guy tried to knock over the sign
[__] yeah dude
oh God it's so much slam me in the head
oh the fact he said it afterwards like
we didn't know that's the most insecure
[__] you can do is if you [__] up and
you fall down and get up and say I fell
down
dude that is a 10. that is a dude he
turned around and said slimy it's over
in the head dude we saw it it was on
video that's so good
dude
oh
that's still one slam me in the head
still went for it still went to go put
it down dude
those are designed to stay up you know
look
the guy recording does nothing doesn't
even say [__]
slam me in the head dude I'm recording
that that is I'm I'm not recording I'm
copying that dude that's so funny
holy [__] that one's a good that's a 10.
that is a 10 on the deserved scale
didn't get too hurt deserved it was
gonna [__] up the property
set myself in the head stand in the head
jumping a ramp on a Mobility Scooter
well this has such potential
the Supercar Nigel testing out your
skills don't give a [__]
oh oh
the Supercar Nigel dude you can't take
that up at all huh I mean that's how
hard disease
oh that where we stopped it unbelievable
dude oh we hit it oh [__]
oh we hit his head bad [__] did he have
a walk man like what the fella
oh [__] the lady at the end
I mean somebody says literally under
this sadly you could tell he died
testing out his skills on the scooter oh
oh
you [__] up dude that's like us five
because he got too hurt but my God man
why did his Walkman fell out fall out
why'd he ever Walkman you know
everyone's crazy all right
as there's Nigel you know everything's
so British
oh you die cheerio
kicking the ball
oh hell yeah hit him in the face
10. it wasn't that funny though so maybe
a little bit less than 10 but that was
good here's another here's a here's the
oh that's the one I just did okay
okay let's look at these tender ones
here we go baby modern dating in one
picture it says
Petra 32 verified
I'm no longer dating if you're
interested in me I need a 500 word essay
on how you will not waste my time
actually that's pretty cool
Jesus that's actually not cool now that
I think about it immediately afterwards
because that's so [__]
man these people think that they like
are a catch you're not really a catch
dude there's so many [__] people out
there
you know
you're only a catch after the person
realizes you're a catch
right people who seem to be catches
they're [__] the craziest people of
all
you can't think you're a cat walk around
thinking you're a catch you can if
you're a dude honestly because that
makes women like you but dudes don't
like that [__]
you think of a woman who's like oh yeah
I'm a catch all right you know what I
don't want that [__]
here's another one
like And subscribe baby
like And subscribe
there we go
when did you move here a year a half ago
how about you are you a native
and then the person for the top says
cool do you live with roommates I moved
here at 17. he says why do you want to
know are you trying to pay my bills
because if not I don't see why
who I do or don't live with concerns you
and then after that
[__] loser
so goddamn harsh
people are on the internet are just a
brutal
they're just
[__] atrocious
um and it's not real life so great
all right guys uh
oh you sent it to me hell yeah dude
amazing uh you guys thanks so much uh I
appreciate the love like And subscribe
I'll be in Tucson soon christy.com and a
bunch of other places uh getting those
Australian dates sorted out
um so sit tight that's it for the
episode on YouTube if you want the raw
the uncut the unedited version of
congratulations this episode and all the
other episodes go to patreon.com
crystalia and also it's only six bucks
and you get all of the extra episodes
there's many many extra episodes there's
like almost 30 now that you can go watch
just for six bucks so go get that
patreon.com appreciate you guys so much
and thank you
[Music]
thank you